We have seen so far two ways of
estimating an unknown parameter.
We can use the maximum a
posteriori probability
estimate, or we can use the
conditional expectation.
That is, the mean of the
posterior distribution.
These were, in some sense,
arbitrary choices.
How about imposing a performance
criterion, and
then finding an estimate which
is optimal with respect to
that criterion?
This is what we will be
doing in this lecture.
We introduce a specific
performance criterion, the
expected value of the squared
estimation error, and we look
for an estimator that is optimal
under this criterion.
It turns out that the optimal
estimator is the conditional
expectation.
And this is why we have been
calling it the least mean
squares estimator.
It plays a central role because
it is a canonical way
of estimating unknown
random variables.
We will study some of its
theoretical properties, and we
will also illustrate its use and
the associated performance
analysis in the context
of an example.